- Good afternoon, everyone.
I thank you for coming at
this late afternoon meeting
that today I'm going to talk
about discussion control plane.
I'm going to talk about how
the operations will change
in the next two years.
Like whatever you are
doing for running software,
you will dealing it differently
like either yourself
or by using a product.
I'd just like to talk about this quote
from Dario Amodei, CEO of Anthropic.
But in March 2025, like
eight months ago, he'd said,
"AI will be writing 90% of
the code software developers
were in charge of."
So like, I don't know if you
agree with this sentiment.
I don't think that we are there now,
but I think we are coming to them.
If not 90%, it'll be
like around 50% today.
And like considering that
where we were two years ago,
I think this is quite a leap.
And like even if we
are not at the 90% now,
I think we will be in a
very, very near feature.
So that actually sounds super exciting
so that like now we are not, you know,
doing the daunting task of writing code,
but this means that you'll be responsible
of the alerts that you got at 2:00 AM
about the quote that for the 90% of it,
you have no context,
even like maybe less
context on the issues.
And you also will have no
context about the issues
that like the blast radius of this issue
on the other systems
that are probably written by AI again.
So like this area requires something
that is like a new operational
patterning for SREs
and also for DevOps engines
and whoever is responsible
for waking up at 2 AM.
So even today, like, you know,
without even any AI getting into space,
the modern ops is already very siloed.
So like people are
responsible of different parts
of the systems and they
don't care about the rest.
They're always reactively
coming up with action steps
and even if the wrong books
are coming like piling up,
it's about the lessons
learned from the other stuff.
So it's like the people
are just like looking
at the dashboard, trying to query data,
just acknowledging the errors.
And then this is all with
the old school tools.
Here I'm saying
that like you cannot
resolve tomorrow's problems
with yesterday's tools.
That's why you'll be
introducing today something
we are calling as discussion control plane
where your agentic SRE
teammates or any other teammates
will be talking with your systems.
Before jumping it in more,
let me just introduce myself a little bit.
So this is my like
and almost a decade, I'm
working on observability
and first, I started my
journey with observability,
with serverless observability,
and that's how I got become a
Serverless Hero back in 2020.
And I'm actually an ex-developer
who become a product manager accidentally.
Now I'm becoming an developer
again with the powers of AI.
And I'm at my seventh
AWS re:Invent this year.
And I'm really, really
feeling the energy here
about like how AI changes
everything about like every role
and how it'll be changing
in the next year.
So I'm already full of questions
about like how it will be for next year.
So agenda for the rest of today
is that we will talk about
like what I mean by teammates.
So we will talk about what is assistants
and then what is teammates,
and then we will then
talk about the challenges
of running LLMs on streaming data.
And also, we will link it
with the guardrails on
data on telemetry pipelines
because you just cannot send
everything to an LLM, right?
And then we will talk about cultural shift
while after AI teammates.
Like, okay, AI teammate's here.
So what I'm going to do
is like a normal teammate.
So let me talk about assistants
versus teammates first.
So AI assistants are
just like the, you know,
you see them everywhere in a website.
Like, so in every website
there is now an AI teammate
that's great at fetching
relevant information.
For SRE use cases,
it's always like, okay,
I'm asking a question,
I'm curious about something.
Okay, it's helping me to
query my ask in PromptQL
or in whatever query
language that you're using.
It's good at like retrieving
data from a dashboard,
but it's not like, you know,
you need to be following
up with the discussion.
You need to be telling that,
"Okay, I got my answer,
but is this actually helping me?"
So they're always like by
design passive helpers.
So they're not just there to
actually to resolve the issue
for you, but they are just like there
to answer your question so
that you can resolve the issue.
But, you know, this is good.
Like, this is like what
we have been using AI for
for quite a lot time of time, right?
But like this is kind of passive.
So the actual difference
between a teammate
and assistant is rooted from
an action versus information
with AI teammate versus an assistant.
As I said, like the AI assistants
are like response to prompts
and just like, you know, gives an answer
and wait for the next question
while AI teammates can
proactively initiate the actions
and start, how can I say?
Doing the research about the issue
while you didn't even ask about it.
And for AI, the scope
and the memory is all
about like the questions
that you're asking.
It only remembers the previous questions
and the previous discussions.
And the AI team makes
is like the multi-turn
and they're like the,
"Okay, I did something
but it didn't have the solution
so I need to do something else."
And from that perspective,
like we can see AI assistants
as helpers while you can look
at the AI teammates, your collaborators,
like almost like your junior
engineer that gets better
and better with everything
that they are learning.
Again, the context of it is
like the AI teammates can know
like something other than the prompts
that you are giving to it.
You can learn about like how
is your service map looking at,
how is your dependency map is looking at?
And like you can understand
that like the AI team must
know your systems more than you
and then this's how actually
you can trust on them
and they can act anonymously
between the boundaries
that you put them for it.
So you can say that, "Hey,
I want this AI teammate
to do this stuff, but not that much."
Maybe you can just admit some actions
and you can say that,
"Hey, I want certainly
an approval permission
for these type of things.
So that's like, let's talk
about a real-life scenario
that we have been having a Edge Delta
that like we are
anonymizing the names here.
But, you know, this is
like an a way to start,
one of the ways to start a
discussion with AI teammates.
Like as a human, you can just
go and ask a question to it,
but there might be other ways,
like a monitor can trigger
a discussion before
or like an external event
or a periodic task can
trigger a discussion.
This time, this is like
a human asking a question
about, "Okay, I'm seeing something wrong.
I'm not sure if it's a incident."
I'm just like, I just want
to check something happening.
So like this is normally
how you would behave on Slack, right?
So you will say that, "Okay,
yeah, something seems off,
like can we just check?"
And then it starts here.
So there is an orchestrator
for this all AI teammate
that knows all the AI
teammates in your system.
So let's say you have like 10 AI teammate
and then one is responsible
for SRE, one is responsible
for writing code, one is
responsible for design, let's say.
And like orchestrators, in our case,
it's OnCall AI at Edge Delta,
like looks at all these teammates,
looks at all their tools,
looks at all their permissions
and looks at it all their memory
and picks a teammate
that is the most suited for this question.
In this case, it is like the SRE
and it's giving it a prompt about like,
"Hey, I want you to run this analysis
to answer this question."
And it comes with these questions,
but I like to take your
attention to this approved thing
because like it is asking for
a permission before moving on.
This is like how you actually
can configure a system
to act in the boundaries that you set.
It's asking humans to
get an approval for this,
and then it starts its analysis
and it pulls the first
chart it can retrieve
right into the thread.
Then it goes back to the orchestrator
and orchestrator says,
"Yeah, I did some analysis.
Maybe like there can be some other stuff,
but like, do you want me to go for it?"
And then human user says, "Oh,
I have some idea what
can be happening now.
So I'd like to ask more questions about it
and like, can I also like
look at the log patterns?"
And again, the orchestrator
pulls up the other teammates
just to look at this question.
And then the other teammate
is asking for another approval
and then pulls this data.
But like I really want to
take your attention to here
that like normally if
you would be, you know,
this person who's trying
to resolve this issue,
you would switch between tabs.
You would say, "Okay, now
I need to look at patterns.
Now I need to look like..."
You will go to some dashboards
and like all of a sudden,
you will find yourself
like the 10 browser tabs
open at the same time.
But here everything is
actually in a context suite
just in a thread.
And then, you know, this
conversation takes long
and then after some time,
some other teammates came
in, like it's re-reported
and then colonize or identify
the problematic comment
in the latest deployment.
And then it's asked for like,
do you want me to add rollback
and user requested the
rollback and it's the rollback.
And then the next step
would be like, okay,
you can maybe continue analysis,
but then you can continue
foraging for issues.
So it is like the issue is resolved
like with minimum human involvement
and this human doesn't need to know
about like how to query data,
how to orchestrate the actions.
It's just like asking questions in any way
and then let the AI
teammates do their work.
So I just wanted to talk
about one more thing that here
that like, as you can see
now, like in this thread,
it's all preserved, all
the charts that are,
all the data that is
retreived for this purpose,
all the charts that are drawn
for this purpose are now
preserved in this thread.
You can always go back as a human user
and see what actually happened,
but like more importantly,
your AI teammates can go back
and see what happened there.
But running LLMs on
streaming data is, you know,
more difficult than said.
So like some of the
telemetry data sets are kind
of more suitable for running with the AI.
So logs and events have starts on them now
because like they are
more compatible with LLMs
because by their nature,
they are like diverse
that are tokenized by LLMs
and that like any log line
actually can mean something
to an LLM.
Similarly and like events
like the Kubernetes events,
such events actually means something
and like the LLM has
enough context about those.
But like they are easy
to understand for LLMs,
but they are not easy to,
you know, just feed LLMs for
because like they comes
in the petabytes of scale
and you need to actually
find a way to like, you know,
allow it to feed the
LLM in a distilled way.
Matrix entries are also,
you know, interesting,
like you cannot just like expect LLM
to reveal the trends for you,
so you will need to do a boring job
of like, okay, there is a metric anomaly
so I need to pass it to LLM
and like similarly at traces,
I will do a distributed
tail something on traces
and pass it to the LLM so that the LLM
can do analysis after all.
You cannot just dump all the
metrics and traces to LLM
because in this case,
you will go bankrupt.
So it is, as I say,
like it's efficient data
processing requires for terabytes
or petabytes of data,
but it allows you to run
the queries in English.
But the scalability of course
is not the best thing that can happen.
So for that thing, actually,
like I see people that, "Eh,
tokens are getting cheaper, like, ou know,
we can maybe in the future
just feed everything to LLM."
You know, no matter
how cheap they will be,
like it will be still
very expensive at scale.
And like the training,
like the fine tuning models
with your own metrics is
infeasible for most of the data.
And actually not very spoken
truth about data flowing
to AI is that we are just
letting everything out.
So we are just like, okay,
LLM, just read everything,
read my code, read my data,
read like all my intellectual
property, it's all yours
and it's like exposing a risk.
And teams are now busy
with managing the data following to LLM.
And at this point, like we
come to telemetry pipelines.
So when telemetry pipelines are first out,
they were being used for like, hey,
like let me just compress this data,
archive it in a destination
and it'll just like make me, you know,
store my telemetry datasets
like in an S3 bucket.
And then it is just like
keeping the data safe
and then, like we discovered nicer ways
of like the seeing data
and we like did cost actually,
you know, go by like another,
like 100 times.
So we could send the data to Splunk
or Datadog, but you know,
like if you just ingest
all this data to those,
so you will also go another bankruptcy.
And then that's why telemetry
pipelines came into space
to reduce the data, to filter the data
in an intelligent way and to mask data.
And this was actually what we know
as telemetry pipelines today.
This is good value but
it is not strategic.
It is about like, okay,
now I'm reducing the cost,
but like I don't still make
the data speaking to itself.
And for that value, now we have evidence.
Now using telemetry pipelines now,
like, which is also
costing 100 times more,
using telemetry pipelines,
you can just provide high value to AI
but while still keeping
the data under control.
And there's also, you know,
I know a lot of companies
that just like complying with
all these security things,
but like security certificates,
but they are just
sharing their source code
and their architecture
just bluntly with LLMs.
And then like with telemetry
pipelines actually,
you can say that, "Hey, I
like to really mask the data
that goes to, you know, LLM."
I can just say that, "Hey, I don't want
to send my, you know, anything about,
like any information about my users,
any information about their PII
and also about like my own
code, my own service topology,
I don't want to just leak
the important details."
And actually when you have the masking
and filtering capabilities
before the data goes to
telemetry pipeline, sorry,
before the data goes to LLM,
it's actually protecting not only you
but also your customers
and also your new hires that
you will hire in next month
about like, they will
not be blunt using it.
So you may say that like,
now agentic SRE is here now,
like, are they taking our jobs?
Like what's the role of
us in this new paradigm?
I believe this is more like an elevation
rather than just like replacing them.
So as human people,
you will still be responsible
about the risk management.
You are still responsible of the mistakes
that LLMs can make
and then LLMs can
actually create problems.
So you will need to
focus on how they behave.
You will need to change their behavior
by just changing the
tools that they're using,
changing the models that they are using
and changing the data that they are using
and you'll need to
actually be managing them.
And you'll also move
in like an upper layer
in the organization or risk
management perspective.
And then you'll focus on more complex case
and you will just like maybe go shift left
on the development flow
about like how to respond issues
before they actually push the production.
And you'll be the ultimate decision makers
about like how LLMs behave
and like how humans should
be focusing on these jobs.
So this brings me to the
end of my presentation.
So if you have any questions,
we have a booth over
there, Edge Delta booth.
So we will be happy
to talk about these questions there.
Thanks a lot for listening to me today.
(audience applauding)